THAT SET OFF ON A MISSION TO THE
"TITANIC" WRECKAGE SITE OFF THE
COAST OF NEWFOUNDLAND.
THE TITAN BEGAN ITS NEARLY
13,000-FOOT DESCENT BUT THE
VESSEL AND ITS FIVE PERSON CREW
VANISHED IN LESS THAN TWO HOURS.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME A
MISSION TO THE "TITANIC"
SHIPWRECK HAS GONE AWRY.
20 YEARS AGO SCIENCE EDITOR WAS
SENT ON ASSIGNMENT ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE "TITANIC" IN A
SUBMERSIBLE WHEN HE GOT STUCK.
>> I FELT A LITTLE BIT OF A
BOOM, DIDN'T YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> LOOK AT THE SIDE.
>> ARE WE STUCK OR WHAT?
>> Reporter: WE APPEAR TO BE
WEDGED ALONGSIDE THE PROPELLER
BENEATH THE WRECK OF THE
UPSIDE-DOWN STERN.
>> LUCKILY THERE WAS A
THREE-PERSON CREW AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO BREAK FREE, A MOMENT
CAPTURED AND CAMERA.
WATCH THIS.
>> Reporter: AFTER HALF AN HOUR
VICTOR'S PILOTING SKILLS AND
COOL-HEADED ATTITUDE WIN THE
DAY.
WE'RE OUT?
>> JOINING US NOW IS THE
SCIENTIST, THE JOURNALIST AND
AUTHO
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
WHEN I READ YOUR ACCOUNT I WAS
SO SHOCKED BECAUSE YOU DON'T
EVEN LIKE GOING UNDER THE WATER
AT ALL.
AND SO WHEN YOU GOT THIS OFFER
AS A JOURNALIST AT ABC NEWS YOU
FELT YOU HAD TO TAKE IT BECAUSE
OF WHAT YOU FELT YOU WOULD SEE,
AND THEN YOU GET STUCK IN THE
PROPELLER.
YOU HAVE A PERSPECTIVE ALMOST NO
ONE ON EARTH HAS OF WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO GO DOWN.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
EXPERIENCE GIVEN WHAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH LOOKING FOR THIS
RIGHT NOW?
>> YES.
GOOD MORNING.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I HAVE A DEATHLY FEAR OF WATER.
WHEN I WAS INVITED TO BE THE
FIRST TV CORRESPONDENT TO REPORT
FROM THE "TITANIC," MY IMPULSE
WAS, OH, GOD, NO.
OF ALL THINGS I DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
BUT THEN I HAD TO DO MY JOB.
WHEN WE GOT STUCK DOWN THERE,
TWO AND A HALF MILES BENEATH THE
SURFACE, IT WAS THE SENSE OF
BEING BURIED ALIVE UNDER THAT
MUCH WATER.
AND I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO TELL
YOU HOW TERRIFYING THAT IS
BECAUSE WHEN WE FIRST COLLIDED,
THERE WAS JUST A SENSE OF
ORIENTATION.
WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING AND IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL, SUNNY DAY, ON TOP OF
THE WORLD, YOU'RE THINKING
EVERYTHING IS GOING GREAT.
AND THEN SUDDENLY, SOME OTHER
CAR COMES OUT OF NOWHERE AND
SLAMS INTO YOU.
THERE'S THAT MOMENT OF CONFUSION
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
ONCE WE REALIZED THIS WAS A
SERIOUS THING, THE SUB FELT
SILENT BECAUSE NEITHER I OR MY
DRIVING BUDDY WANTED TO DISTURB
THE PILOT ON THE EDGE OF HIS
SEAT MONITORING THE SITUATION,
SPEAKING IN RUSSIAN TO THE
MOTHERSHIP ABOVE US.
WE THOUGHT, WOW, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS?
MY SCIENTIFIC BRAIN STARTED
TICKING OFF ALL THE WAYS WE
COULD GET OUT.
YOU REALIZE THERE IS NO WAY OUT.
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NORTH ATLANTIC AT THE BOTTOM.
YOU CAN'T CALL AAA TO TOW YOU
OUT.
I EXPERIENCED ENORMOUS SADNESS.
THE ONLY WAY TO DESCRIBE IT AS
IF THE WEIGHT OF THE OCEAN CAME
DOWN ON ME.
I THOUGHT OF MY WIFE, WE WERE
NEWLYWEDS.
IT WAS MY ANNIVERSARY.
I ULTIMATELY EXPERIENCED A SENSE
OF PEACE.
ALL THREE THESE 72 HOURS
THINKING OF THESE SOULS DOWN
THERE AND I KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING.
I WONDER IF THEY'RE STILL ALIVE.
WE'RE HEARING NOISES, BUT WE
CAN'T TELL WHAT THOSE NOISES
ARE.
WE'RE PAST THE POINT WHERE
THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF OXYGEN.
NOISE TRAVELS VERY WELL IN
WATER, MUCH BETTER THAN IN THE
AIR, AND WE'VE BEEN LISTENING
FOR IT.
IT MIGHT JUST BE A PIECE OF
METAL OR A PART OF THE SHIP
BANGING TOGETHER.
WE MAY NEVER KNOW.
WE MAY NEVER RECOVER THIS
VESSEL.
>> LET ME ASK, WHAT ARE YOU -- A
LOT OF PEOPLE POINT TO THE
PEOPLE ON THE SUBMERSIBLE AND
SAID SOME OF THEM HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE.
THEY'VE DONE -- THEY WOULD KNOW
WHAT TO DO IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS.
YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO TO
SOME DEGREE WHEN YOU ARE
WATCHING THE CAPTAIN OF YOUR
SHIP OPERATE, ARE THERE THINGS
HE WAS PREPARED FOR, PROTOCOLS
OR IS IT MAKE NOISE AND PRAY?
>> WHEN WE WERE PREPPING FOR THE
DIVE, THE CAPTAIN PUT US THROUGH
ORIENTATION AND TOLD US STORIES
ABOUT PEOPLE IN THAT SITUATION
WHEN THEY PANIC AND IMMEDIATELY
THEY WANT TO GO TO THE ESCAPE
HATCH WHICH IS, OF COURSE, A
DEATH SENTENCE, BECAUSE WHEN YOU
PANIC YOU'RE NOT THINKING.
SO I KNEW THAT WHEN WE COLLIDED,
THAT'S THE THING I DIDN'T WANT
TO DO.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE NOBODY
ELSE IN THE SUB WAS AND I WOULD
GANG TACKLE ANYONE WHO EVEN
LOOKED AT THAT ESCAPE HATCH.
FOR EVERY PROBLEM THERE'S AN
OPTIMAL SOLUTION.
I'VE DRUMMED THAT INTO MY SON'S
HEAD FOR EVERY PROBLEM THERE'S
AN OPTIMAL SOLUTION.
IT IS THE MOST TERRIFYING THING
COMING TO THE CONCLUSION, NO,
THERE AIN'T A SOLUTION.
THERE IS NO SOLUTION, PERIOD.
THERE'S JUST NO ONE AROUND, AND
I IMAGINE THAT AT SOME POINT IN
THESE FIVE FOLKS ON THE TITAN,
THEY CAME TO THAT REALIZATION.
YOU COULD HAVE ALL THE
EXPERIENCE IN THE WORLD, BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY THERE'S ONLY
SO MUCH YOU CAN DO.
NO AMOUNT OF TECHNOLOGY, NO
NUMBER OF PLANES, ROVs, SONARS,
NOTHING, NOTHING CAN COME TO
YOUR RESCUE.
IF YOU'RE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
OCEAN TWO AND A HALF MILES DOWN,
YOU DON'T JUST GO DOWN THERE AND
REACH IN EVEN WITH A CABLE OR
GRAPPLING HOOK.
PRESSURES ARE ENORMOUS, BONE
CRUSHING, IT'S COLD DOWN THERE.
I JUST FEEL -- I'VE BEEN FEELING
FOR THE LAST 72 HOURS THIS
KINSHIP.
IT'S UTTERLY DARK, NO LIGHT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LIGHT A CANDLE
AND USE UP THE OXYGEN.
THIS HAD TO HAVE BEEN A